من كان يريد ان يقيس حراره العلاقات بين
واشنطن وتل ابيب ليس بوسعه ان يفوت ما
يطلق على هامش مؤتمر ااك من رسائل يتبادل
فيها الطرفان عهود التحالف الابدي منبر
قوي النفوذ اكدت المندوبه الامريكيه لدى
الامم المتحده نيكي هايلي امام اعضائه على
ان الزمن ادانه السياسات الاسرائيليه في
الامم المتحده قد ولاى في اشاره الى
القرار الاممي الاخير الذي اذان الاستيطان
دون ان تستعمل اداره اوباما حق النقض ضده
ود متبادل بلغ حدا جعل خمسه من كبار قاده
منظمات يهوديه امريكيه يحذرون مما سموه
العلاقه المبالغ فيها بين نتنياهو واداره
ترامب ودعوا الى التوازن في علاقه اسرائيل
بالجمهورية لقرار الجدد هناك انه دعم وصف
بالمطلق وغير المشروط تردد صداه في
المؤتمر السنوي للجنه الشؤون العامه
الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه معركه اسرائيل هي معركتنا
يقول نائب الرئيس الامريكي بل ان مايك بنس
يبشر المؤتمرين بان الرئيس دونالد ترامب
يدرس بجديه نقل السفاره الامريكيه الى
القدس المحتله التي تطالب بها اسرائيل
عاصمه موحده وابديه وتلك كلمات اطلقت في
غمره الحمله الانتخابيه الامريكيه لم ينسه
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي فقد دعا حليفه
الجمهوريه الجديده في البيت الابيض الى
التعجيل بتلك الخطوه في كلمته امام مؤتمر
ااك عبر الاقمار الصناعيه كرر نتنياهو
طلبه بان يعترف الفلسطينيون باسرائيل دوله
يهوديه دون ان يؤكد صراحه الالتزام بحل
الدولتين وهذه مساله ترسل اداره ترامب
اشارات متناقضه بشانها كان تختار سفيرا
لها في اسرائيل احد اكبر المشككين في ذلك
الحل من اساسه او ان يتحدث الرئيس
الامريكي نفسه عن انفتاحه على خيارات
بديله مربك هو مثل هذه المواقف كذلك الذي
لا يدين الاستيطان اليهوديه في القدس
والضفه الغربيه صراحه لكنه لا يمنحه الضوء
الاخضر في الوقت عينه في حاله نادره ادين
ذلك النشاط الاستيطاني دوليا بقرار من
مجلس الامن في اواخر ايام اداره اوباما
بعد ان تمنعت عن اشهار الفيتو في وجهه لن
يتكرر ذلك تقول السفيره الامريكيه لدى
الامم المتحده ولن تقرع اسرائيل في
المنظمه الدوليه بعد
الان كلمات نكي هالي الحازمه امام اكبر
لوبي داعم لاسرائيل في الولايات المتحده
لا تقبل التاويل ولمن لا تزال تساوره شكوك
توضح السفيره ان اداره ترامب اتخذت خطوات
لطمانه اسرائيل بان هناك شرطيا جديدا وفق
تعبيرها وبان السياسه الامريكيه تغيرت
تغيرت الى حد تقلق بعض تفصيلاته قاده
كبارا في المنظمات الرئيسيه اليهوديه
الامريكيه انهم يقصدون العلاقه المبالغه
فيها كما يصفونها بين نتنياهو والرئيس
الامريكي الجمهوري يخشون ان تتحول العلاقه
الى قضيه سياسيه فتؤثر بشكل كبير على دعم
الحزب الديمقراطي لاسرائيل
وللحديث عن هذه القضيه تنضم الينا من
واشنطن جل ريني عضو منظمه ان ليس الان اف
نت ناو وكذلك الدكتور خليل جهشان الخبير
في السياسه الامريكيه والمدير التنفيذي
للمركز العربي في واشنطن مرحبا بكما سيده
جيل ما خصوصيه المؤتمر هذه السنه في عهد
اداره
ترامب اعيد السؤال سيده لل ما خصوصيه
مؤتمر ااك في عهد اداره
ترامب شكرا شكرا على
الاستضافه في هذه السنه هذه السنه يمثل
تهديدا غير مسبوق
يضا بالنسبه للكثير من الاقليات وايضا
تؤشر ب 50 سنه من الاحتلال هذه الحركه
الحركه لليهود الشباب وايضا التي تتمتع
بدعم المجتمعات المجتمع اليهودي في
الامريكي تتخذ موقفا ترفضه اي بااك اي
بااك تمثل رمزا ل الاحتلال
في ولايات المتحده
واتخذت حركتنا موقفا تاريخيا وقررت ان
تقاطع المؤتمر هذه السنه قاطعت موه ولكن
ما لم تحدثيني عن خصوصيه انعقاد هذا
المؤتمر بما حمله من تصريحات ناريه لاهم
شخصيات اداره اوباما في هذه السنه ما الذي
قدمه المؤتمر في هذه السنه مغاير عن
السنوات
الاخرى
ان المؤتمر اك في كل العام يصر ويدعم
سياسات اسرائيل ويدعي انه يمثل مجتمع
اليهود الامريكيين ويصير على ان يقدم دعما
كاملا للاحتلال في الحقيقه ان ايباك يصر
على ان الامريكيين اليهود يجب ان يتركوا
مبادئهم
مبادئي تخبرني وتصر على انني ارح احب
الغرباء وان احقق العداله وايبك سنه بعد
الاخرى تطلب منا ان نتخلى عن مبادئنا
اليهوديه وان ندعم الاحتلال باي ثمن وهذا
ياتي بعد في في بعد 50 عاما من الاحتلال
وقد قلنا كفى والكثير من اليهود
الامريكيين رفضوا هذا الامر قمنا بالتظاهر
وبرقص وب تلاوه الصلوات والاناشيد وطالبنا
بانهاء الاحتلال خارج هذا المؤتمر سيد
خليل جهشان كيف ترى يعني هل ما قالته
السفيره الامريكيه لدى الامم المتحده نيكي
هايلي في مؤتمر ااك يعبر تماما عن رؤيه
الاداره الامريكيه
برايك ا طبعا هي عبرت
بوظيفتها يعني ك ك ك سفيره لهذه الاداره
في الامم المتحده عبرت عن طبعا وجهه نظر
هذه الاداره
المشكله ان هذه الاداره ليس لها مواقف
رسميه بعد ليس لها مواقف واضحه بعد فكان
هناك في الماضي في الواقع عده تناقضات بين
السفيره نفسها وبين البيت الابيض تناقضات
بينها شخصيا وبين الرئيس ترامب فلا احد
يدري اذا كانت بالفعل هي تمثل وجهه نظر
جديده او سياسه جديده لهذه الاداره ولكنها
بدون اي شك تمثل انحياز هذه الاداره لوجهه
النظر الصهيونيه المتطرفه لوجهه نظر
الحكومه الاسرائيليه المتطرفه اولا في
معاداتها لحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني وثانيا في
في دعمها للاستيطان
للما تسميه في الواقع بادانه التجاوزات
الاسرائيليه من قبل الاسره الدوليه التي
اعلنت وفاتها ولكن طبعا هذه الادانات
ستستمر يعني هي ليست من شان فقط الولايات
المتحده هناك اسره دوليه كامله دعم مثل
هذه الادانات في اروقه الامم المتحده وهذا
لا يعود فقط الى اداره السيد ترامب سيده
جيل كيف تنظرين الى ما تم ارسائه في داخل
هذا المؤتمر بالنسبه للقضايا الرئيسيه مثل
المستوطنات مثل نقل
السفاره مثل حل الدولتين وبالاضافه الى
الملف الايراني والدعم ايضا اللامتناهي من
قبل الاداره الامريكيه لاسرائيل داخل
المحافل الدوليه هل تم ارساء شيء واضح
في الحقيقه لا استطيع ان اتحدث عن الموقف
الذي اتخذه قاده ايباك هذا العام لكنني
اعرف انه كما قلت في الوقت الذي نقترب فيه
بالسنه الخ للاحتلال فان ايباك تصر على
الاحتلال باي
ثمن منظمتنا لا
تتخذ موقفا لاننا في حقيقه
الامر نريد ان ننهي دعم المجتمع الامريكي
اليهودي للاحتلال وفي حقيقه الامر نحن
نركز على ما يوحدنا وهو الاصرار على
الحريه والكرامه لكل الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين لذلك لا ليس لدينا موقف تجاه
حل الدولتين ونحن نعارض الاستيطان ونعارض
الاحتلال لانها في انعدام كرامه
للفلسطينين وكيف ستتصرف برايك اسرائيل
بناء على ما تم ذكره في هذا المؤتمر من
حقيقه الدعم الكبير لهذه الاداره للرؤيا
الاسرائيليه الكثير من اليهود الامريكيين
لديهم انا ليس لدي عائله لكن الكثير من
اصدقائي لديهم عوائل واقارب في اسرائيل
ويعيشون هناك حيث ان الاسرائيليين قد
هاجروا وزاروا هناك والكثير من اليهود في
العالم وخاصه في الولايات المتحده وايضا
في اسرائيل لا يريدون ان يرتبطوا
بالاحتلال غير المنتهي مجتمعنا يستحق امرا
افضل ونحن نصر على ان نقف بعد 50 عاما من
اجل دفاعا عن القيم اليهوديه وان ندعم
الحريه والكرامه لكل الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين ان الاحتلال يمثل كابوسا
للفلسطينيين الذين يعيشون تحته لكنه ايضا
يمثل ازمه اخلاقيه للاسرائيليين والشباب
الاسرائيليين مجبرون على القيام واتباع
السياسات اللا يوافقون معها ونحن ويجبرون
على ترك مبادئهم اليهوديه من اجل
الدفاع عن اداء الخدمه العسكريه والمساهمه
بهذا الاحتلال العنيف الكثير من الشباب
وخاصه حول العالم موحدون ضد الاحتلال ونحن
حركه في تزايد وفي اتساع سيد خليل يعني
كما قلت ان هناك ملفات لم يتم حسمها ليست
واضحه بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه الملفات
الرئيسيه ولكن ما قالته السفيره الامريكيه
في الامم المتحده كان واضحا جدا خاصه
عندما تحدثت وقالت بانه يعني خوف الجميع
في المنظمه الدوليه من مجرد اثاره الحديث
معها عن قرار
2234 برايك يعني ما الذي ما الذي يعنيه
مثل هذا النوع من الحديث الحديث عن انها
ستكون شرطيه داخل الامم
المتحده بالطبع هذا هو الدور غير المنطقي
الذي قبلت هذه الاداره كما قبلته في
الواقع ادارات سابقه لها في الماضي
بالنسبه
ل يعني تقليص الدور الامريكي من دوله عظمى
الى دوله فقط تدافع عن اسرائيل في اروقه
الامم المتحده نتيجه انحيازها للموقف
الصهيوني او للموقف
الاسرائيلي هذا هذا الموقف او هذه السياسه
وهذه الممارسه ليس لها شرعيه اليوم فهي
يعني فقدت شرعيتها ليس فقط في اروقه الامم
المتحده انما فقدت شرعيتها ايضا حتى في
الجاليه اليهوديه كما سمعنا من ضيفكم على
هذا البرنامج هناك انشقاق بين الاجيال
داخل الجاليه اليهوديه حتى في الولايات
المتحده هنا هناك اجيال شابه يجب الاعتراف
بوجودها يجب الاعتراف بوجهه نظرها تعارض
ولا تريد املاءات الجيل القديم الذي في
الواقع سخر مصالح الجاليه في هذا البلد
لمصالح الصهيونيه ولمصالح
اسرائيل فيجب علينا ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار
كل هذه التغييرات فطبعا سفيره الولايات
المتحده باستطاعتها ان ان تتكلم
امام يعني ايباك امام مؤتمر ايباك وتدعي
ان عصر انتقادات اسرائيل قد انتهى ولكن
بصراحه الاسره الدوليه لا تتفق معها حول
هذا الموضوع وهذا واضح في جميع قرارات
الامم المتحده وسنرى ذلك سنرى المزيد في
الواقع من هذه الانتقادات في المستقبل رغم
انف هذه الاداره ووجهه نظر الرئيس ترامب
المنحاز سيده جيل هل تري بانه داخل ااك
هناك مقاربات مختلفه ربما لاداره هذه
العلاقه الثنائيه بين واشنطن وتل ابيب وهل
من الضروري ان تمر من خلال رؤيه نتنياهو
لهذه
العلاقه هل بامكانك ان تعيدي السؤال لو
سمحتي هل تريي بانه داخل منظمه ااك هناك
مقاربات متعدده لاداره العلاقه الثنائيه
بين واشنطن وتل
ابيب
في حقيقه الامر احد الامور المهمه حول هذا
المؤتمر ان الكثير من اليهود الامريكيين
ليس لديهم خبره في السياسات الخارجيه وليس
لديهم علاقات قريبه ووثيقه مع اسرائيل وهم
يشاركون بايباك من قبل موظفيهم او مقبلي
جامعات وهو اعد من
اجل خلق نوع من الجهد الطبيعي في المجتمع
اليهودي لكنه في الحقيقه هو يدعم سياسات
اليمين ولا يتماشى مع المبادئ اليهوديه او
مبادئ المجتمع اليهودي الامريكي احد اهم
ربما الامور المعارضه لنشاطات ايباك وما
قلنا به اننا استمرينا
بالترحيب بال الحضور من اجل ان ينضموا
الينا شكرا لك سيده جل ريني وانت عضو
منظمه ان ليس الان اف ناو شكرا لك على
المشاركه من واشنطن وايضا اشكر الدكتور
خليل جهشان الخبير في السياسه الامريكيه
والمدير تنفيذي للمركز العربي في واشنطن
شكرا لكما ختام الحصاد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء